it's my distinct pleasure to introduce
you to Kevin Ryan Kevin is in the class
of 85 for some of you that that may
sound old but Kevin don't worry because
I'm in the class of 77 Kevin is one of
the leading Internet entrepreneurs he
helped build double-click how many of
you have heard of double click okay and
he founded and his chairman of a long
list of companies and I'll just read
them mongodb who's heard mongodb work
frame a nomad health and he also had
found founded and was the chairman of
Business Insider and guilt to me though
despite all these wonderful things he
has done what I think is so terrific is
he sits on the Yale corporation and
spends countless hours working to
advance Yale's interests and I'm so
grateful to him not just for being here
today but for all he has done for Yale
so please join me in welcoming him I
[Applause]
don't grate well thank you for that
introduction and I am excited to be here
because the two things I spend the most
time on our entrepreneurial activities
and Yale and this sort of brings it all
together so it's a perfect fit we just
finished the corporation meeting it is a
big commitment
it's an incredible institution you know
so we were here Thursday from 3 o'clock
through dinner yesterday we had meetings
from 8:00 in the morning till through
dinner at 9:00 last night and this
morning from 8:00 in the morning until
one o'clock we just finished and that's
that's a board meeting and we have four
or five board meetings a year so it's a
big film but it's also an enormous
institution with a lot of things going
on countless numbers of schools once you
get into it you realize that there's a
whole parts of Yale that you probably
didn't know about because you're either
an undergraduate or in the forestry
school you're in the med school we went
to toward the right laboratory yesterday
which I had never seen and is is quite
extraordinary so anyway that part's been
great and we can I can answer any
questions later on about that but what
want to talk about mostly it was just
what you're thinking about you're
thinking about work
somewhere in the new economy let's say
and first of all that's the right
decision you're on the right room
everyone should be here it is the most
fun you know it's a shorter for me to
think that when I arrived at Yale which
does sound do you guys like fifty
billion years ago but to me it doesn't
feel like it was that long ago but you
know no one even had a computer I mean
no one on my floor had a computer I bet
some of you have a computer yeah and so
it's so just in a short period of time
though you know my entire career has
been defined and I'm known for spending
twenty years working in the internet
which didn't exist as a name or an
industry even as I was graduating from
Yale
so there was there was the beginning of
the internet that existed out there but
not a single person in normal life knew
about it so if I said to you I think you
know when you're sitting here in 30
years speaking you'll be known for
having you know devoting your life to
this industry and it actually hasn't
been created yet and you're like how do
I prepare for that that's a little
challenging
and so you that's to remind you you
don't know how things are gonna play out
I'm very hard to predict obviously so
but what we are seeing and I think
everyone here knows this is just a
radical transformation of just every
part of society of education of Commerce
and technology is playing a role and so
that was why this industry is so much
fun because everything is shifting and
changing and sometimes it just gets
categorically replaced you know when I
was in high school there were no ATMs
and so that came in and you know thirty
five years ago and just to replace and
tellers mostly went away and became more
efficient you flow of money all the time
so we've seen full transformation there
other areas you're just seeing the value
being extricated out of industries so
you know Priceline the the most valuable
Internet company on the East Coast so
probably 60 80 billion dollars in value
in Connecticut so that you know if they
don't own any assets and yet I believe
recently we're more valuable than all
the airline's put together so and all
they do is help you find the right
ticket and then airline companies have
to provide you know by 200 billion
dollars worth of planes and they'll fly
them
and then for the last 40 years up until
the last five years never make any money
on that and and and this all that value
was extricated out of the industry by
basically an internet player and so that
is an example of what you're gonna see
across the board across the board so in
some places its category happen and
you're using it every single day and
know these products and in others and
b2b it's happening in a more subtle way
that you you wouldn't see yet unless
you're in that industry so let me give
you different examples of things that
I've been involved with so double ik was
a great run nine years from 15 people
imagine this I'm 30 32 so I become the
president of double-click four years
later we have 2000 employees in 22 5
countries so that's a lot of stuff that
has to happen do we go public 24 months
after the company was started can't even
do that anymore but it was super fun
yeah and so great great company you know
you've worth 12 billion dollars
four years after we started it feeling
pretty good wasn't really worth 12 done
any but was publicly traded it was worth
twelve billion dollars then you get to
the downside where the stock price goes
from $130 to $5 a share 70% of our
clients go bankrupt that's much much
less fun seven rounds of layoffs so when
you go into being an entrepreneur there
are some amazing moments and times that
fantastic and there's some times that
are just it's called them less than
amazing and when you're doing round
after round of layoffs to try and make
sure you can save the company so the
final conclusion was that it wiped out
70% of our clients but 80% of our
competitors so we picked up about 3035
percent of our original revenues from
them so we net lost thirty five percent
we got rid of 50% of our employees ended
up with 60 percent of the world's market
in AD technology and 35 percent profit
margins eventually sold to to Google for
three billion dollars in 2007 and today
if we're independent while you're worth
10 billion dollars it's a huge part of
the Internet infrastructure so great
first experience for me I then since
then have started a bunch of different
companies I have no focus whatsoever I
only think of problems that are out
there what needs to be solved what and
this is what you need to be thinking
about if you're starting a company
which I don't think is the only thing
that people should be doing it at 20 but
at some point your life you should and
you're always thinking of what is more
expensive what is harder what is what is
complicated to do what takes too long
and if you find something like that your
average person just says well I guess
that's just how it is
and but an entrepreneur says wait a
second maybe I can solve that and I'll
work on that so I'll give you multiple
examples there so so we started MongoDB
deeply technical company it actually it
was announced a couple weeks ago that
we're going public right now and so in
the next several weeks companies on the
roadshow now might be priced if all goes
well in probably two weeks last round
was worth about one point four billion
deeply technical database a very hard
company for us to get off the ground so
right now I was like oh my god a huge
success yeah yeah you weren't there in
the beginning when even though the two
of us who had been you know really works
at double-click and were founders and
had sold his company for billions and
you think ok you can raise money but we
had this idea only for a database that
was a different type of database
technically was a different type of
business model it's open source people
didn't have successful open source where
companies where you gave away your
database we had the worst business model
you could possibly imagine which is I go
to you say look would you give us a
millions of dollars here's what how it's
gonna work for two years we're gonna
have to work on building the product
because the credibly complicated product
then for two years we're gonna give it
away
and so after four years we'll have no
revenue but but that's not I'm getting
to the best part the best part also is
that none of us have any database
background whatsoever there's three
co-founders the other two technical me
non-technical so we don't have any
relevant experience really we've done ad
technology which is not at all the same
thing and and at that point you know
we'll start to grow it and it'll be
great since everyone's like business
risk technology risk team risk they just
all passed and so really hard to get
money we scraped through got enough
money to keep going slower than we
thought and then now now every wants to
give us money because we don't need
money anymore and that's what never
wants to give it to you
so but we got to the right place which
is a good outcome started I want to do a
comparison because one month in May 2007
I actually had ideas for two companies
at the same time and normally don't like
do two at the same time but I just
really like both ideas one was guilt and
one was Business Insider and so but if
we checked in two years after I started
both those companies simultaneously
guilt was doing a hundred and
seventy-five million dollars in revenue
which is crazy
two years later so it was just a
phenomena and Business Insider was doing
almost the same thing as long as you
divide it by 100
it was doing 1.75 million in revenue so
if you had asked me or if I had asked
you at the time which company thinks me
more valuable and you've been look yeah
I'm not an idiot
obviously guilt and so fast forward
seven years later actually sold them
both coincidentally within about three
months and sold business SATA for 450
million dollars and sold guilt for 250
million dollars because we could never
really get guilt to make money the
business model was always hard it was a
credible product it's 600 million in
revenue by the way $6 million in revenue
for guilt and business at the time was
doing 45 million in revenue and sold for
more money and so one of the other
conclusions is that you just don't know
how the business model is going to play
out over time there's just a lot of
uncertainty so if someone says to you're
starting a company and like you know
you're not gonna do it because you don't
know this you know this I never know
anything when you start a company I mean
you have an instinct if it's something
can be there but there's gonna be things
that play out that you just cannot
forecast and so all you can do is they
look I'm going after a good idea I think
there's a big enough market I'm gonna
hire great people and have great
execution and I'm gonna learn along the
way and have to adjust some things so
sometimes you start something and it
goes in a direction that you just didn't
forecast and you've got to be smart
enough to strike the middle ground of
not abandoning something right away but
abandoning it if it's really not working
and question always is how do you know
that and that's a judgment call I mean
it's actually no different if a friend
of yours came and said like do I break
with my girlfriend out of it's working
out you know what's the right answer I
mean the answers kind of depends I mean
I have to see the situation no and you
never quite know and so this is a
judgment call it's never easy
but good outcomes on both start a
company called Zola probably forty a
four years ago which is a wedding
registry
and here's another different lesson so
obviously there are gazillion wedding
registries Bloomingdale's target
cratenbarrel Bed Bath & Beyond William
Sonoma
you know Amazon and then a couple
startups so you might have said as a lot
of people did why would you possibly do
that but it turned out I could see that
there they weren't doing what you should
be doing if you register -
Bloomingdale's to get married they only
sell you the products that
Bloomingdale's has and that's a classic
mistake of not thinking of my customer
so if you interviewed 50 grooms and
brides
although Brides statistically Drive a
lot of decision-making they would say
look what I wanted on my registry was
some things from you know a blender and
plates and a couple things like that but
I really also wanted yoga classes
because we're really into yoga and I
wanted help in my honeymoon and I really
wanted cooking classes and a wine bottle
and a tent because we're really into
camping and Bloomingdale's doesn't have
any of those things and so I need to
jerry-rig maybe three other registries
and complicated so the obvious solution
was just have the ability to put
everything in one place and do it really
well next year we'll do 280 million
dollars in wedding gifts its enormous ly
large already bigger than Bloomingdale's
in the wedding space and is we've
launched a sense then wedding websites
so when you get married now you often
have your own website that's a core base
where you can tell your guests and see
where the hotels are they can see what's
coming you can plan the whole tool
100,000 couples in the first 12 months
will use it we're giving away for free
because of course when you use that you
often use the registry and we'll make
six hundred dollars off that so that's
going to be a billion dollar company in
the in the wedding space there's a big
big opportunity no one's done a good job
they're in a space that people thought
was just crowded and not there so it's
really at the end of the day when you're
thinking of these new business models
though you it's unlikely che but you
need to understand the customer
I don't ever put a financial model
together and then when I'm making a
decision now that if you go to the
business school will tell you gotta have
a financial model I was a CFO I have a
CFA a ship
financial background so it's not that I
can't do a financial model it's that you
financial model won't work what I want
to know is is there a product opening do
I have a vision for a product that is
going to be distinctive from what is out
there and if I can do that most of it
will follow so it's just like if you're
gonna start a Japanese restaurant you
would ever knows Japanese restaurants
can make money you can put a model
together and it'll show that it makes
money there's only one thing that
matters is in a restaurant is it full
and so you need to get to the core issue
of what's gonna make your restaurant
full because if it's full everything
will work and if it's empty it doesn't
matter how much you paid for the paper
and the plates and all that stuff it
just won't matter
so make sure you're focusing on that
core core core decision and it's
generally around product so a lot of
things I'm seeing now on things I think
you should be thinking about are more in
the business to business casual a lot of
consumer ideas are somewhat solved so if
I asked you right now you know jeans
you're wearing can you get those online
can you get a hotel room can you find a
date can you go get a ticket
I mean named 20 things and the answer is
in like three minutes I can go on my
phone and solve every one of those
problems so not as many opportunities
there's a chat mode I don't think about
here which is hospitals hiring temporary
doctors so actually there's 15 billion
dollars a year and many hospitals
especially in rural areas have huge
problems because they just don't have a
spinal surgeon for the next three months
because ones on maternity leave or
they're in a ski resort how does a ski
resort you ran us a hospital in Aspen
how do you handle five times more
patients staffing wise during February
than you did in November and so you're
like oh I actually need temp doctors for
that three-month period just like I need
temp ski instructors so it's actually a
huge thing every hospital uses them and
up until now they had to do this by
hiring a search firm so imagine the
search for if I said to you can you find
me a doctor who's a spinal surgeon who
wants to go to Albany New York
February 1st you'd be like I have to
make a lot of phone calls to do that
that is a super inefficient process as a
result if he's going for three months
you'll charge me $50,000 fee just to
find the person someone who's going to
be with me for three months and going
so the conclusion should be that just
feels expensive that peels too much that
doesn't feel right
what is the right solution right
solution is a database what if I had
which is what I do have now 11,000
doctors in there who are all only there
because they're available for temporary
work and they put their dates in there
and they put their criteria so now I can
just go you know Albany New York spinal
surgeon February 1st and maybe 12:00
show up I interview those 12 I pick one
boom I'm done we charge them half as
much because we don't have to go make
all the phone calls so that is going to
be a very successful is it's only two
years old in January really had 800
doctors on the platform now we have
11,000 and we were able to use a
two-sided marketplace right and we had
we cross the valley of death when you
start a marketplace imagine a dating
site imagine a male/female dating site
if you start off and have a hundred guys
and 100 girls on the site it doesn't
work just funding Lee doesn't worry you
on there I'm like what someone who
speaks French and likes classical music
and there are none and so you just
abandoned and you go because it only
starts to work once you have 10,000
people on it or something so we had that
problem and you got to push right
through it very quickly before people
figure out that your product doesn't
work and get there and not now I think
we're pretty much there so that's what
another company so I've moved offices 15
times and as CEO you're you're
responsible for you know doing all the
work but you're making a lot of
decisions and in every single room
including this room someone had to make
decision there was lately like 200
decisions in this room someone shows
this someone shows that how much I was
this I mean there's all kinds of
decisions and so there's actually no
technology tool that allows you to do
that correctly so what we did is create
that tool so I can see on a drawing this
place I can see all the furniture and
where it's going to go I have a we put a
product catalog in there so the interior
decorator who's not even in the room can
pick out 10 chairs ten of these chairs
versions put them on there then I can
say no no I want this one or that one I
can see the price the CFO can then you
can automatically see how the budget is
because our budget was let's say $25,000
for this room but if I start making some
decisions that go above that
to pain so you can see that in real time
then hedda facilities can sign off I can
see all the comments right there if you
guys have used slack ever it's sort of a
version of that and this process just
goes so much faster so it can cut the
time down and the accountability down so
we provide that and with that tool we
also help you if you need an architect
project managers they're not on a
payroll but we have a network
long story short started this about a
year ago and last quarter we signed ten
million dollars worth of construction
projects we're building 20 offices four
squares office we built Zola's office we
have a lot of offices that we're
building right now for this or that
they're using the tool so and I'm gonna
roll out to 30 cities over the next
couple years and solve a problem that
you guys haven't dealt with but if [ __ ]
when we open an office in Dublin and we
have 20 salespeople 25 salespeople we
need to build out an office but we don't
have a facilities person because it's
not a big enough office to have a
full-time facilities person so who does
that like you can take one of your sales
guys and say why don't you do it he
doesn't have any idea how to do this and
it's not going to do it well so I'll
have a team there we could just call
among a call up work frame and do it for
us so just neither other random types of
businesses in a way but our solving a
problem that I have run across ok I'll
tell you what I'm sorry did I'm doing
right now
you're really gonna think it's crazy but
I am I want to build a competitor
Starbucks see I thought you d be a fully
automated so here's the here's the
question right now you go in and you pay
four dollars and fifty cents in
Manhattan and you get a cup of coffee
that no one thinks is like the best cup
of coffee in the whole world and you
wait eight minutes and the full cycle to
get that so the question is you just say
that it could never be done better by
the way the cost of the cup and the
coffee the ingredients it's 40 cents so
I look at that and I think I think I can
do better and I also no point number two
that there is a machine you can get a
machine if you've won have been five
thousand dollars for a machine in your
house a super super nice machine
everyone says it makes great coffee so
we know machines can make great coffee
but yet that's not happening so I'd like
to be a year from now is have created a
machine
you can walk in here and and say look
your iPads here you can make your order
order on your phone no cash no people
clacking you just put it up there see on
the screen Kevin is the second one two
minutes later cause I'll have five
machines so I'll have five times the
throughput of a Starbucks so the ideal
will be no lines at all and we'll have
tested a thousand different versions of
how to make every version of coffee with
a coffee some idiot and so whether it's
16 seconds or 18 seconds or 21 seconds
and it should be boiled at the right
temperature by the way if you drink tea
for example you go to Starbucks and
green tea is served at the same
temperature as black tea no one in the
whole world who knows anything about tea
does that because green tea gets too
bitter but they just can't adapt to that
so it's actually not as good a product
as it should be so obviously these
things always look good on paper right
now I'm feeling good about it and I
haven't done anything yet
I'm actually out interviewing mechanical
engineers and robotics people right now
so I'm gonna build a team and then over
the next ideally six months from now or
six months when the person starts I will
have a prototype of a machine that I can
test if that works I then have multiple
choices I can go do this in a kevin's
coffee not that name but something else
and then start a branded system or I
could sell that machine to a Yale dining
hall or every hospital that has a
problem the middle of the night they
need to serve coffee and it's either bad
coffee Evan complains about it or it
could be in the back of a truck or I was
at the US Open where there's a 25-minute
wait so just think if you see the 25
minute wait like really there just can't
be solved there's no way that in 2017
we're practically putting people on Mars
that we can get you know that I like I
finally I'm going to Yankees game
tomorrow and you have to decide which
inning you're gonna miss when you go get
food is that necessary I don't these
necessary you know it's costly so doing
that okay I'll just tell you two more
quickly I have a lot of companies but
just the idea is to give you a variety
of the things that you can be doing and
be thinking about because it's not just
the internet thing that you're using
every day there's a problem that you're
not being about at all which is end of
life
the last 12 months so anyone my age
their parents are going through you may
have grandparents going through it right
now and the last 12 months
there are about 25 things that you will
need to buy that you haven't thought
about yet and don't know how to buy
what's your favorite wheelchair rental
vendor you know probably not probably
not you have to figure out wills and
probate court probate court is a
different state by state so you got to
figure that out ahead of time you may
need to buy some things for my mother we
need to get something that is near the
bathtub because we don't want her to
fall and she's getting a little unstable
so there's a whole bunch of stuff there
I got to figure out how to how to do
that
there's eventually at some point for
everyone there's a funeral there's a
funeral home there's speeches at the
funeral home there all kinds of things
that you have to figure out and haven't
dealt with before the information online
is terrible it's totally opaque so right
now if I said you can you get me a hotel
room in Lago dugu for Saturday night
you'll be like yeah give me three
minutes and I'll have you for choices if
I said to you once you go find me a
burial plot in New York City there's
only 25 cemeteries can't be that hard
right can't be done not online can't be
done can you price comparison shop
funeral homes and caskets nope can't do
that intentionally want to take
advantage the fact that you're feeling
terrible you go in there they tell you
it's five thousand dollars for a coffin
you're like it seems like so much like
it's your father
you know like okay when that's not how
you should me if you want to spend that
that's fine but maybe there are other
choices that are that are better for you
so that's the one and the another one
b2b is this is coming I didn't actually
found I'm the lead angel investor in
which I occasionally occasionally do and
so solving the problem that when you
have a product that you want to make
that is made of plastic injection
molding so half the things right here
all the stuff is is plastic this is
injection molding everything there so
you make it often in China right now
apply 50% in China there are thousand
factories in China they do that which
one are you gonna choose in and why and
also if you even talk to me really to do
this for a living like oh I visited
three and that'd be the Quillen if I
told you my daughter's my brother's
applying to college and you know she met
someone who went to Montana State so
she's thinking of going there
hey like that's not how you choose a
college you there's a data information
fee what you want and so that doesn't
exist it and so we will have vetted 250
factories put a hundred on the platform
out of those hundred when you give us
your drawings or you put your drawings
in will route it to the right 25 in the
same way that you'd route it to the
right 25 colleges if you knew the
candidate and then we'll get 20 bids
back and then you can decide to go visit
them and opposite them choose but you'll
you'll we will save you six months of
work free to you every factory will give
us three percent of the order if they
get the order so it's on contingency
so that launches in about four weeks so
look there there are opportunities
everywhere this is changing every aspect
of society and so you are in the right
place right now and so things to think
about as you go career-wise is that one
don't make think of how you chose a
college I'm appalled
actually appalled at how people in all
colleges including Yale choose what they
do after yet and here's what by my my
daughter who probably is going through
what you went through has visited I
don't know 15 colleges so that's
probably 15 days and then spent I don't
know many hours studying for SATs it's
like that and then another forty hours
filling out the application so there's
probably two hundred three hundred four
hundred hours of work going in to figure
out something that actually is not that
important so if what I mean by that is
if you had not gone to Yale you weren't
gonna just like go straight to prison
you were gonna go to some other very
very good school maybe not quite is good
but really good and frankly you know
people at be schools Harvard things like
that they do fine made your [ __ ] you
know you can still you can still make it
no the point is there's a lot of good
schools and you know and you would do
just as well now the decision you're
about to make about to make when you
graduate is actually more important it's
more important because you what a lot of
people do is just oh I don't know
Bank of America is coming on campus so
maybe I'll go there and then they made
me an offer I'm like okay it seems good
so that's just like if I told you my
daughters
even apply to people who send you know
pamphlets to the house that's terrible
and you will find out of your 10 friends
20 years from now at your reunion that
maybe half are still in the same
industry that they went into day one
even though they didn't choose it
consciously there's got an offer and so
you and its end you run a risk of going
down the wrong path but I mean with that
you could get an offer from Time
magazine so let me just make fun in Time
magazine for a second
Time magazine is you could be a
career-ending thing for you and so first
of all go look at Time magazine ten
years ago and look at it today and see
if you even tell them apart you can't
because nothing's happened so it's not
even interesting but I'll give you
example I just interviewed someone we
went to a great Ivy League school who
was at a publication like Time magazine
and she's been working there for
actually about 810 years and and she
wants to do something online with me and
I'm not gonna hire her because she
doesn't have digital experience she's
already stuck so what's she gonna do you
know she's geez now it has to go back I
said to her if you're not I can do this
and because I'm not gonna make the offer
you need to get into digital very
quickly or your your career is just
gonna stall Time magazine is about a
business and I don't know who's gonna
hire you at that point that someone
who's 32 I mean they're people be on a
path example I sometimes given before is
the Procter & Gamble trap with apologies
to everyone here because it's a great
company and I'm sure some of you use
their products everything but out of
business school it's known for great
marketing
great marketing your father will tell
you great marketing you should go do
that so you're like I get this offer
that's cool I go work there the problem
is you're pretty good at your job see
what happens two years later you get
promoted now you were managing now your
senior manager okay see let's go and
then you know two to three years later
you get familiar to get to like see I'm
director then you go to one of your
means and you see your friends who are
working at Amazon and doing a start-up
and doing this and then solar energy and
and then you wake up one day like you
know what I don't care about the tire
goal of my unit which by the way if you
work for pampers they had forty four
point one percent market share last year
and the goal and it's a stretch goal is
forty four point two percent this year
which represents by the way like five
hundred million dollars of extra memory
so you know they should try and do that
but you like really that's what I'm
gonna spend the rest of my life I didn't
even consciously choose pampers as a
career I don't even care about pampers
and so what am I gonna do now and then
you come interviewing people like me and
like it's great but you know your
classmates been working at an e-commerce
company for seven years so why would I
hire you who've been doing this huge
scale and from my point of view learned
bad habits
they don't even transfer to a small
company and so an you have now a spouse
who has a job in Cincinnati with you and
what do you do and so you want to be
thinking about the industry you're going
into you want to feel although you can't
predict the future that these are good
skills these are good things happening
you have a run that you can see yourself
there ten years so now 20 years now
obviously there's a chance that you'll
switch and people do switch I have
switched in my career
it can't happen but sometimes it doesn't
happen as much or as you want and people
can get stuck so these are very very
valuable moments and you need to use
your summers so my son graduated last
year and was able to get all the jobs he
wanted work for an internet company in
Paris
my wife is French and so at a French
passport and but he walked in having had
worked a summer at Warby Parker heavy
worked a summer at Twitter and having
worked a summer at zola and so they're
like wow that's a ton of internet
experience great everyone made an offer
because he had fully prepared and spent
those summers doing it if you walk in
and say look I worked at the summer camp
you know one summer was just really
great and then I did some random thing
here and it's a minor thing there that's
just not gonna have you compete with the
guy next to you the woman next to you
who has relevant experience so use those
summers use your time here you need to
be a knowledgeable consumer about what
you're going into what you're doing the
third thing is use Yale as much as you
can to be as technical as you can I'm
not technical I'm not a programmer I
took one or two courses
in Fortran which has been super useful
in 1984 three but and not that everyone
here needs to be a computer science
major at all but this is the time for
you to take some CS courses take some
data science courses those skills are
incredibly important you will regret not
doing that and it doesn't matter if you
are gonna get a B and you saw you get an
A if you took something else it doesn't
matter this is the time of your life to
build those skills it will only become
more important and you'll regret it and
it's very hard to do afterwards
technically you could but you probably
won't this is the time to do that so be
as technical as possible be as well
informed as possible and go down do it
down the paths which are going down in
this career it's just more interesting
if you've always wanted to go into
banking I went into banking by the way
for four years and I loved it but I see
a lot of my son's friends who went into
banking wasn't really conscious they
sort of showed up and they're only two
months in right now I saw them all you
know a couple weeks ago and 50% of them
hate their job and you don't want that
you know you're coming out of Yale you
should have choices in some ways it's
your fault if you don't have the right
choice it's not even just choose I want
this company I wanna get that job but
the career you want to go into that you
love that you're excited about which
could be one of 50 many many great
things to do go do them but just make
sure it's a true conscious decision and
it helps when you've spent time by
listening and thinking like right now
you know during this whole two-day
period you're gonna be thinking a little
bit about this and maybe you conclude
yes love it but you might come out and
think I really like health care and I
want to do health care but to healthcare
tech or something else whatever it is a
million choices but make it consciously
so let me do this I'm gonna I'm gonna
wrap up and I'd be happy to talk about
topics on any number of subjects things
you know everything obviously startup
related technology related fundamental
trend related anything Yale related I've
been on the board for five years
on that I spent a bunch of time in
political policy areas so everything to
do with York City State at various
points considered running for office in
some things
Arnold I ever will but I've thought
about that and I spent a lot of time
with the Cuomo ministration and the de
Blasio ministration and thinking about
especially Tekin policy how do we use
technology better as a city and a state
and then I have a bunch of geopolitical
interests I'm the board of Human Rights
Watch I'm very involved with Mercy Corps
I was on the board of Doctors Without
Borders so a lot of global health and
yeah not that I'm an expert but I do
spent some time there so have you talked
about anything you wanna talk about
yes this is an unusually answer I I
don't I've had very few companies that
ever not worked but the hit ratio
normally would be much lower
I've had many individual failures within
those so you know I would double click I
bought a company called abacus for a
billion dollars through date a company
really a great idea until I sold it
three years later for 200 million
dollars so I lost eight hundred million
dollars oops don't do that don't do that
turns out people don't like it so I
launched as part of guilt guilt taste
beautiful sight food category
unfortunate parent I was the only person
who thought it was a really good idea
because hardly anyone came to it and we
spent ten million dollars and closed it
down which is not as bad as when I
launched Park and bond which is a
full-price men's store on gilt and that
didn't do well enough so we lost twelve
million dollars on that and closed it
down
so along the way and that's not
including hiring people you know set up
a big office in Scandinavia that we lost
20 million dollars on so we have scale
many things are gonna go wrong so I had
had a company called Panther Express
which was a competitor to a Cabaye years
ago that ended up selling but lost a
little bit of money everyone lost a
little bit of money on that I have a
company right now that I started a year
and a half ago called
it was Denver right which is a [ __ ]
Business Insider but it just aimed at
the Denver market but not for business
for just News IDO competing with the
Denver Post and so sold it to a company
that does the same thing in Philadelphia
because I'm not sure I don't feel as
good about the ideas I did so I'm a
shareholder there so if you go into the
space you are going to have many things
that go wrong and you have to think of
yourself like a professional baseball
player and so if you said I want to play
professional baseball I just I just
really can never get out it just
stresses me out like okay you can't play
baseball because good players are out
60% of time 65% of the time you have a
you know you're a failure all the time
and so as an entrepreneur you have to
think about that if you wait the reason
entrepreneurs have lots of failures part
of it is you have to move before you
know the right answer
because if you don't someone else is
gonna do that and then I'm gonna be six
months or a year behind so if you said
how are you gonna know that these
Starbucks competitors things are gonna
work obviously don't and I can do five
years of research and then I'd have a
better chance of knowing and guess what
someone the problem is there's too many
good entrepreneurs in the world and
there'll be 20 of them out there that
are eating my lunch when I started guilt
I thought oh my god I knew this business
model because in France there was a
company won't play baby I was doing this
very successfully most people sure
didn't know that so I thought this is a
great idea I was gonna borrow this idea
from France launched it here it's gonna
be awesome
big head start so started in May
launched in November it's hard to launch
much faster by the time I launched
another company had already launched
they were already working on in their
garage somewhere
a week later someone else launched
relola it's still around and a week
after that hot look launched so now my
big head start turned out to be no head
start I was one of four competitors at
the same time always going to happen
after that yeah yeah I think of it as
pivoting but yeah so yeah so sorry
they're there sometimes you have an idea
in the beginning and you just hit the
idea right and you're doing the same
thing in eight years later and except
that doesn't happen that often so
sometimes you can have it totally you
have to change your your business model
because you conclude it's not working
[ __ ] the original model for [ __ ] was
not a database company even though it's
gonna be the first database company in
25 years ago public so it all sounds
great we were gonna do
cloud computing infrastructure which was
a very very good idea in 2007 it's sort
of obvious today but in 2007 there
weren't that many companies building
cloud computing infrastructure to do
that you needed to do a whole bunch of
things and we bit off more than we could
choose so of a year in we concluded that
we were building a database we're doing
all these six different things and we
thought oh my God we're not gonna be
able to raise a hundred million dollars
which it wasn't be necessary to do this
without any proof points and we're
making great progress in the in the
database area so we stopped doing 80
percent of what we were doing and just
focus on the database so that was a good
example they're really changing in terms
of Business Insider it was less pivoting
then you can't start a worldwide
business magazine with two employees
right that just doesn't work keep people
The Wall Street Journal doing that you
have to narrow down what you're doing so
we only did New York tech the name was
actually Silicon Alley insider and so we
did a good job in New York technology
and then started to slowly expanding so
it wasn't pivoting was just expanding
out and you normally have to do that
start narrow you know gilt started with
just one sale of women's clothing per
week and two and three and then eight
months later
men's and then kids and a bunch of
things that worked and then some that
that didn't work so yeah things you
there's no formula you're always looking
every quarter you're literally looking
your business going is this working
I've learned a lot now and do I feel
good about it and do I want to continue
doing it once in a while I haven't had
it but you could you could make the
right decision just shut it
down and say it's not working and
actually I think there's a bigger
problem of people continuing too long
than people giving up entrepreneurs are
by definition congenitally optimistic or
else they wouldn't be doing crazy stuff
like this that are low probability
competing with a whole bunch of existing
players unless they're really optimistic
that's good to get them going and it's
bad because I'll hear people coming in
saying oh you know I know we missed our
numbers last year and it's not going as
well as I thought but I've got a bunch
of new ideas it's gonna work now then a
year later like yeah yeah those didn't
work but wait till next year
I've got some new things and a certain
point you like your relationship is not
working out you know you need to break
up and that's a tough decision cuz you
have to admit failure instead she was
your first one now I don't feel I don't
care as much
nothing's have worked if something
doesn't work I just shut it
I shut it writes out well one you know
there are people that are very very
happy doing consulting and it's a great
skill base so I'm actually relatively
positive on doing that you have to just
figure out whether that's what you want
to do you know some people like it some
people don't like it at all
so I'm building they're not going to be
that great at I look I think if you can
go down the technical path I think it's
a it's a good idea so you know there's
such a shortage of people with technical
backgrounds that even if you're not
planning on on programming for 25 years
even if you do for a year or two will
give you great skills that you know in
it you can always go out you can't go
back in so you can become product
managers you know everyone every VC
wants to back someone that has a
technical background understanding but
good interpersonal skills that's like
the perfect candidate and
disproportionately do well now by the
way a lot of candidates who are running
and starting companies have backgrounds
like mine liberal arts you know are okay
in math and things but don't really know
how to program but have are close enough
that they can do it it
the day let's not forget that your job
as a CEO is to hire and motivate people
that is the job and even if you're
whether you're technical marketing
finance whatever you're gonna have five
people in those five categories under
you and your real job is can you attract
great people and can you do will they
stay well they work hard well they work
together and so I tell people that I
thought some of the best training for me
in doing what I do today was running
student groups in high school and
college so I've I was ran a lot of
student groups I ran the Liberal Party
here I ran the Yale college student
Investment Group student council in high
school that sort of thing in classic
stuff that you guys have on your resume
from high school but those those that's
really great training because if this is
a student group and I'm running it no
one has to be here right the moment your
board are not feeling good about it
usually like I'm too busy I got a test
coming up and you don't show up and so
it's actually good training for startups
where people do not have to show up
because they can go across the street
and get a job in a second it's not like
other companies where they're locked in
forever so you need to create a
environment that is fun for people and
you're doing the right thing and mission
driven you have to believe that they're
doing something that is mission driven
you're not paying them so I thought that
was great training yeah so for me so
obviously four years invested banking
business school then two and a half
years working for Disney in finance I
was making the transition there were
very many startups at the time then I
went and went and became the CEO and CFO
of a division of a media company 180
people and we had to do a turnaround of
that and then in 1995 I read about the
internet and I launched an internet site
for that company was called the Dilbert
website you know the Dilbert comic
strips we owned peanuts and Dilbert and
things like that and so business-wise it
seemed like a really good idea because
we could go directly to consumers and
not have to sell it to a newspaper so at
the end b96
I went to the parent company and said
look this internet thing is going to be
Hugh
and it's hard to remember that most
people went out on the Internet at that
point like half of people probably
didn't have an email address just didn't
use it so I went to I meant old man and
we have a head start so why don't you
give me a couple million dollars and
I'll build up internet division as a
loyal corporate citizen this is the
right thing to do so they in their
brilliance came back to me two months
later and I was like freakin two months
is a long time and said we think the
internet could be a fad it turned out
actually not really it said it's going
pretty well
so they kind of missed that one yeah and
they thought if you're successful you'll
cannibalize our current business which
of course is the thing you learn a
business cool that's a stupid point of
view because if you don't cannibalize it
I got across the streets gonna do it so
you might as well do it
so then I said but this led to the whole
decision I said okay I pitched my idea
to you you've clearly whiffed on it so
I'll go do it myself and therefore I do
believe this internet thing is gonna be
big I think it may be the most
fundamental thing that happens in my
lifetime for business-wise which it has
been and so let me go do that so I went
out to start a double-click and ran
across it's part of my research there
were two companies doing something
similar in AD I thought advertising
kanata technology's gonna be a big part
of it
at the first company they weren't very
impressive so I was like great at the
second one and I was very impressed with
them and they had a great technology
tool and I realized I didn't they
created the the dynamic ad targeting
that controls all of Internet today and
I was like wow I don't really know how
to do that yet
and they said won't you come join us and
so I did that instead of starting my own
so people I feel I thought thought I
found a double-click but I didn't really
I was just a very very early employee
yeah
yeah you also mentioned we also just
mentioned the you know you know you got
a large background and you know how do
you square the the kind of the tension
between that because like someone who is
trying you know because like you if you
devote yourself to a lot of things in
college and high school experiences but
then like if someone if you know
potential theoretical hiring manager you
says I'll be longer are you which one
wins out like how do you how do you
afford honestly how do you on as the
hiring side you know you manage that
tension yeah so bristle there's
different types of jobs so there are
some type of jobs that you just wouldn't
have any experience in in college you
know in doing but that's why I'm really
focused on using your summers is your
summers you have flexibility and I think
certainly your last two summers you know
those are big opportunities if you want
to go travel and do something else
that's great but you're paying a price
for that because you are you're not it's
not just that you make yourself look
better to get a job is that you figure
out whether you like this or not so my
son it's been was thinking startups and
was thinking government he loves he did
Global Affairs here so he worked in DC /
summer and that was very useful and then
he concluded he didn't want to do that
where is he thought he didn't want to do
that then he did it start I was like
okay I do want to do that
so you need a couple bites at the Apple
because it's hard to know when you're 21
or 20 or 18 or 19 what you like to do so
you just want to see that and I think
some people can use a little bit more
time you don't wanna spend your whole
time in four years looking for a job
you're you're at Yale
you should be exploring all kinds of
cool interesting fun things that you
want to do here invisible but at the
same time it doesn't make sense to spend
zero time doing that and so when you're
hiring people you know look sometimes
you're just looking for some people with
people with raw brain power and that can
work but a lot of times you'd like to
know that this person wants to do this
is gonna like it
and I feel more comfortable if someone
has done a slightly
our thing I'm like okay did I just do
you risk this a little bit then someone
who's just like I have no idea what you
do but I'm here and not there so that's
all right that's why I would I still
spend most your time on the core yell
experience and some of it thinking about
your next step and same is true in
business goals even more should be more
focused or forestry school or anything
else yeah so what do you think about
student entrepreneurs and the innovation
weaving student buddy yes oh well a
couple things for you and I'm very
involved on many elements of Yei and I
was on the community to find the person
actually a friend of mine that we found
who and Irma galkin who's heading up
city we're trying to really do yell one
of our areas of focus is to encourage
our entrepreneurs more and more ten days
ago I hosted 80 people in New York City
80 jelly's ranging from people graduated
a year ago who've just started a company
to talk about to meet Andrew to meet Ben
[ __ ] the provost and to talk about
how we're gonna support entrepreneurs in
New York City and other places so we're
trying to do a lot more of that and
you'll can do more and they are starting
to do more which is good so in terms of
entrepreneurs here look I think it's I
don't discourage people who I'm doing a
start-up at this age but need to know
that most of them don't work there's a
sweet spot of successful startups in the
internet space and it's sort of 26 to 40
now could be younger could be older but
actually if you go through the top
hundred companies relatively few are
outside of that ban in consumer
companies in in enterprise software it's
a little bit older there's I think
there's a lot of benefit to you joining
a existing startup it could be a
25-person company it could be a hundred
200 that's growing really quickly
so that you can learn a little bit more
about management you can see things in
action you learn a area cuz you're gonna
be in marketing or product or program or
something there's a big learning curve
there that is very very helpful having
said that there are some see that I'm
involved with some successful Yale
startups for spring spring care is a
company that started a year and a half
ago won the Harvard Yale startup
competition and I'm the lead angel
investor in that uses artificial
intelligence to help doctors
antidepressants very cool idea and
getting a lot of traction they're gonna
raise around soon so you can't you can
have some great ideas that that can work
and it can be a great experience whether
it works or not most people I was
talking to someone who just did a
start-up we had probably 20 people in
there zero to five years out of Yale at
my house and some of them didn't work
but they still felt like their
experience they learned more during
those two years then they could have
done using doing anything else so you
have to feel passionate about the idea
and that can either happen or not happen
you know not everyone has an idea ready
at that moment and if you don't have it
then go do something else if you do have
it you just can't let it go
then you need to assemble a team and do
it the reason 21 year olds have trouble
having successful startups is that they
have trouble hiring senior enough talent
to work for them and that you like if
you can do it with all 21 year olds
that's okay but then when you start
saying I'm gonna go I gotta met with the
team that wants to do a new type of loan
product they have to close deals with
all the Ivy League institutions and
they're having trouble getting in the
door they're having trouble closing that
that's the hardest part but it can be
done look you know Bill Gates did it
Mark Zuckerberg did it yep some of those
so what most people say right now that
you know we're in the very very early
stages of AI and so that's gonna
reverberate you know everything
everything but still is just a subset of
using technology so I don't worry about
the fundamental to company but all those
areas are forward-looking you know
autonomous vehicles drones big category
but but even within these sectors
sometimes it's not a breakthrough you
know technology is just using like
nomads now breakthrough technology but
it's gonna be very successful company
and using technology in a better way so
that's a pretty good thing to to do
there yeah but the the good news is look
we're seeing impact
everywhere yeah I'm at the Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs I'm
interesting technology for a development
and I was wondering like how do NGOs or
different development agencies Human
Rights Watch or Mercy Corps attract the
kind of ideas and talent in in
technology for from the data scientist
or whatever to be able to better empower
all the bigger impact yeah and I did
work with both them on that and so one
they were hiring people and then they're
hiring they're using outside vendors as
well in a really cool way so I have one
more company to talk about system one
system one uses Internet of Things
devices to measure the output of medical
devices in Africa so let me explain your
USAID you give twenty five million
dollars to the government of Mali to get
machines that did tests for tuberculosis
and so you've advised a thousand
machines they're in a thousand rural
hospitals then you know what happens
three months later a third of them have
been sold for parts and aren't even
functioning that's bad for the people
who don't get the benefit it's bad for
you as an ID because that article is a
terrible article when it comes out and
it supports the idea that it's all
corruption and terrible and so these
guys put a little device in each machine
then the results come back so you can
see in every single hospital how many
positive
how many negatives from yesterday's
tests what's the output the output is
that one it discourages you from selling
it for parts because we'll know within a
day to that we can actually see
outbreaks you assume that people see
outbreaks cover Molly doesn't even know
when there's an outbreak of tuberculosis
somewhere it could be months before they
find out and meanwhile thousands and
thousands of people infected third is
that there's a problem that you
definitely want thinking of the vial
problem you need these vials that they
are part of the test so you have to
supply them to the hospitals they expire
over I don't know a month or two months
um so simultaneously what these
organizations know is that half our
hospitals have run out and so they're
doing no tests these have have too many
and they're expiring and there's no
connection so you'd say well pretty
obvious connection but you need the data
and so one of these veils you now they
think they lost twenty million dollars
maybe of expired vials
wasting this is one and that's one type
of test one area the number could be a
hundred million dollars overall I don't
know how big it is and so now we can
connect those and so say look we need 50
vials to go over here to these guys and
which saves money and saves people's
lives or things like that so those good
examples of I mean I didn't think of
this this time an investor but I'm like
oh my god that is a mission-driven great
business doing four million dollars in
revenue after two years so great stuff
happening out there and so there ways
for everyone like you with your
background to really help make the world
a better place and do that in raghava
you're doing all right well I we have to
break you know I don't well a little bit
I don't think that's the driving force
but it does I think it wanted you use
technology better so I can give you some
appalling stories about how New York
City both his use technology well in the
police department and then you know I
still can't pay my parking ticket with
my phone and that is just a terrible
thing it's terrible for me but it's also
more terrible for New York City because
you get a paper parking ticket and then
you lose it so they don't get the money
for two months they have to spend five
dollars to send you a reminder which you
may or may not get and then they get the
money three months later maybe
and so that multiplied by millions could
be solved right there there's all kinds
definitely that so using technology
effectively they're you running
organizations much faster but a lot of
it I think in politics is is not linked
to that it's a more broad set of skills
if you're gonna be mayor or controller
it's the core skills of hiring great
people and making good decisions and
execution I mean the dishes I'm
interested in are ones that are really
executive positions not legislative
positions and so be CEO
so hopefully I'd pitch that I'm a better
CEO most people that we elect Bill
DeBlasio
had managed 40 people in his life ever
and then the next day was managing
300,000 so if that were a company no one
would ever hire that person not that
he's done a terrible job but you know
that's a big leap and
we could use people that have I think
had more managerial experience in those
positions voters don't distinguish
between senator and and governor they
think they're kind of one person can do
both of their interests in politics but
they're totally different one is a
50-person staff and one is you know
10,000 or 50,000 people so all right I
need to wrap things up but thank you all
for being here and I'm glad you're doing
what you're doing and excited that your
interest in this field
[Applause]
[Music]